Pickle Rick!
Huh, This seems kinda fancy.
Gary for all you know this is the equivalent of an alien truck stop you have no frame of reference
You're in a universe beyond your imagining, but yes, it is super Fancy
My blood is green!
my blood is gasoline!
nope regular blood
New Rick and morty everybody let's break it down
And I added the title sequence to this too because we finally got the new one
There's a bunch of new scenes
So it's pretty easy to tell which ones are fake and which ones are new so I'll start with that
But there is a new round of the merch Giveaway
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber leave a comment on this video
I announce winners at the end of videos. So here we go starting with the title sequence
It's basically an alternating pattern of fake real fake real fake so there's five scenes starting with season two
They were a little more consistent
I'll play a little bit of the intros from season one and season two so you can compare just chopping off the bits that are
the same the first scene with the math
Problem and the eyeball floating by in space and the last scene of the monster chasing them into the title is the exact same in
every single case
So you can see that in season one there were a lot more fake scenes
It wasn't till season two till they started alternating the fake real fake real fake but interestingly enough
They still include five separate scenes whether or not
They're fake or real
Love the first one of beth catching morty looking at naked women on the internet only their butts have been swapped with their faces
Surprise surprise everybody has butt faces. So we'll just call this the butt based reality
I don't even want to think about the logistics of that then there's the real scene with summer in
terminator summer inside the galactic government looking like they're trying to help rick out then by the logic of
Alternating fake scenes with real scenes this must be fake with all the morty's trying to help each other escape little lizard morty creeping out
The side even if this piano scene isn't from episode two
We know that it's real because we've seen it in the season 3 trailer in all of that confirmed footage from the season in this
Last one is probably one of my favorite ones
I mean the butt face one is pretty awesome
but I love the idea that rick goes to the morty store shopping for new Morty's based on the
Accessory weapons that come with them and as he selects one and walks away without putting the other one back you see that
They're all alive and there, as his face gets all wide as it gets ready to smash it on the ground
Let me know in the comments though
What's your favorite part of the new intro?
butt faces, or the morty store?
Most of the stuff they've been dropping is in service of hyping up Sunday's episode with the exception of the non-canonical adventures
But we talked a bunch about the pickle rick scene where he basically tries to cheer morty up because they're all bummed out because Jerry's
gone
And he gets himself into a literal and metaphorical
Pickle as he becomes a pickle that falls down into the sewer and has to prevent himself from being eaten alive by rats
That was the animatic that they released at comic con last year
oh YEAAAAHHHHH
So what'll happen is they'll probably continue posting clips through the weekend
I don't know if they'll be posting this many clips after every single episode, but whatever ends up happening
I'll totally do a video for it. So leave all your bonus video requests in the comments below
I know a lot of you been asking for the comic-con panel. So here's a little bit more of that
I'll post the rest of it on Saturday morning
There's nothing more therapeutic than spending way too long on a season and then looking back on it and going
That's only 5 percent more genius than the past two seasons
So we're going to work on... I feel like I can do it now. I can write really fast
That's the cold open to
and the rest of it will be padded..
Will there be there be a plot here?
the cast have had it with Justin riffing about along, discontinued Szechuan sauce
Szechuan Sauce or some product Thar i don't..
See that guy right there, we got one of the pros
Really guys guys. I have to tell you you waited in line for so long for this panel
And I'm going to give you a crazy like exclusive little nugget of information I
am officially
going to be getting a
big, liter bottle of the original recipe Szechuan sauce
from McDonald's delivered to the Rick and Morty offices and we are
Definitely going to film the taste. We're all gonna taste it. We're all going how riot come enjoy the real thing
This is actually going to happen. It's happening
I think it's coming next week or something it would have happened if you didn't wait in line
But what I'm telling you here. I saved it for this moment. What was it different?
How old were like yeah cool good for you?
We want to try it... weren't we teeing up like a bit like where it was like
Oh, just another show this season is going to be awesome. Just a reminder that
It's supposed to be episode two just based on the TV guide
So I'm just assuming that that is correct
So what will happen is is I'll post my video on Monday morning after it airs just because so much game of thrones stuff will
Be happening earlier in the evening
Congratulations to renee's nisbet. You're the latest Rick and Morty Merch Giveaway winner. It's just from their zen monkey studios
Please private message be on the back end of my channel so I can get your contact details
while you wait for everything you can click here for more Rick and morty season 3 episode 2 and you can click here for the
Trailer for next week's game of thrones. Thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight